what's a good way to get introduced to
Islam the the faith the the spiritual
experience of it well I think look you
go to uh you know our websites you go to
whyislam.org you go to you come to
yakin's website y.org you go to multiple
Islamic
websites to get those questions answered
but there's nothing like going to a
mosque there's nothing like actually
going to a mosque and meeting Muslims
and asking
questions and I tell people like you
have to step out of your comfort zone
and go there and let your world be
complicated a bit experience it listen
to the sermon meet people from different
backgrounds and ask questions Muslims
love to be asked by the way about their
faith because they're so sick of hearing
other people talk about it so Muslims
love to be asked about their faith
Palestinians love to be asked about
Palestine because they're so sick of
other people talking about it so uh ask
questions and uh you will have them
answered but there's nothing like a
physical connection there's nothing like
a human connection so uh definitely try
to reach out to your local Islamic
organizations and meet people how
difficult is it to convert to Islam
takes 20 seconds
man okay what's involve simple
you you you you you testify to the one
there's no pool there's no baptism like
I I often joke with people I'm like all
right we got the pool in the back we're
going to do the baptism now um you know
uh it's it's literally um testifying to
the Oneness of God and testifying that
Muhammad uh is his final messenger and
so that's called the shahada and when
you testify to the Oneness of God and to
uh the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him being his final Prophet you are
accepting what what's known as the six
articles of Faith six articles of Faith
are belief in one God belief in the
Angels belief in The Messengers so you
can't be a Muslim without believing in
Jesus or Moses or Abraham or Muhammad um
to believe in the messages that God has
spoken to humanity uh through divine
revelation the Quran being the the last
uh Revelation to believe in the day of
judgment and to believe in Divine decree
and predestination so those are six
articles of Faith so when you testify um
to the Oneness of God and to the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him being the
final messenger that's called the
shahada you embrace the package of those
articles of Faith that's the implication
then you learn the prayers you learn to
fast in Ramadan um you give what's known
as zaka the mandatory charity 2.5% of
your retained earnings and uh Hajj which
is the pilgrimage to Mecca if if you can
so that's the growth part the journey um
you know once a person takes the
testimony they then grow uh it's really
interesting because we always have uh
those people that convert to Islam like
a week before Ramadan or even a day
before Ramadan so uh you're Muslim and
you got to fast the next day uh you know
and that's always a challenging
experience for people but a fulfilling
experience for many people um when they
Embrace Islam at that point and again I
mean it's it's
it's it's simple and I think that the
beauty of Islam to many people is in its
Simplicity one God one Humanity one body
of prophets um and uh one
community